welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man 3 video
tom hall
trying to do his darndest not to spoil
the movie for a couple minutes
the spider-man 3 interview that he did
posting this video is actually way
longer so i'll explain the other stuff
he said about the movie during this
for some reason they just cut it down
before they posted it if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there's going to be a
bunch of spider-man related stuff
happening really soon and there's also a
bunch of big super bowl trailers that
are coming this weekend
so we know about a couple marvel ones
that are coming i'll be doing videos for
all that stuff too
the reason why he actually did this
interview in the first place is because
we're in the middle of movie awards
season so he's hyping up a couple of his
projects spider-man 3 among them but he
also did a movie with the russo brothers
separately from marvel called
cherry so he's hyping that up as well
obviously he's talking about spider-man
3 being their most ambitious movie so
far
it's the third movie in a trilogy
obviously sequels have to escalate so
you would expect it to be even bigger
than spider-man far from home
and because he's getting on in
spider-man years he's been playing the
character for a long time now
people are starting to wonder how much
longer they're going to keep doing tom
hall and solo films
so even though there are rumors about
them doing spider-man 4 with tom holland
like sony's already said they're making
it for spider-man
film but we don't know a lot about the
plot yet because we haven't even seen
spider-man 3.
they made a billion dollars on
spider-man far from home so of course
they want to get that billion dollars
for spider-man 3 and how do you escalate
things to guarantee yourself a billion
dollars
you go full spider burst so he did have
some funny things to say about all the
andrew garfield toby mcguire rumors and
the other big spider-verse stuff the
internet has been talking about for the
past few months since they started
working on the movie
he kind of fumbled his way through a
very similar type of answer as he was
giving when he was talking about the
ending of the movie like oh of course
you want me to give away the end of the
movie and i almost did
i love the way he does come clean about
that during the video he says you almost
got me to answer all those spoilery
questions
but he kind of fumbled his way through a
tobey maguire andrew garfield
answer like the kind of answer you would
expect him to give when sony and marvel
are holding guns to his head
outside of the zoom frame while he's
speaking i believe his answer and a
couple of the other cast members who've
also been asked
similar questions about andrew garfield
and toby maguire have all kind of said
the same thing
mostly i don't know anything about that
if they're in the movie that would be
great that sounds like something that
marvel would do
like yes we know about all these rumors
we know what the internet has been
talking about all these posts that have
been going on
and there was another reason andrew
garfield rumored just a couple days ago
because a delivery driver who was taking
food to the set in atlanta where they're
filming spider-man 3
claimed that he was delivering food to
andrew garfield so why would andrew
garfield be near the set of spider-man 3
if he weren't shooting a cameo for the
movie
a lot of people also noticed during that
clip too tom holland is kind of misusing
the term
standalone movie spider-man 3 is not a
standalone movie it's the third film in
a trilogy but i think the way he's using
that term standalone he's just talking
about the separate solo spider-man
movies
as opposed to avengers infinity war
avengers end game
or movies like captain america civil war
where spider-man is only one of the main
characters
instead of being the lead the follow-up
joke to that though is that spider-man 3
seems like it's got so many characters
in it even though most of it is just all
rumors and speculation
that it seems like tom holland's
spider-man is just a side character
in his own movie like which cameo are
you most excited about i'm most excited
to see if tom holland is going to get a
cameo in spider-man 3.
i've already talked about this in the
past too i think the idea is
all this cameo stuff whatever winds up
being true most of those people will
just be small parts of the movie
and even without them they've already
confirmed that dr octopus from the tobey
maguire spider-man films and electro
from the amazing spider-man andrew
garfield films are going to be in the
movie their confirm
so you could call it a spider-verse
movie even without tobey maguire and
andrew garfield coming back
i also got a lot of questions recently
about the viral spider-man 3
social account for flash thompson so
there's the spidey number one fan
account that's been posting a lot of
spider-man 3 stuff recently and it's
actually real it's not just a fan
account pretending to be real
sony and marvel use it for viral
marketing for the spider-man movies they
did it back for spider-man far from home
as well
it was meant to be a viral account
created around the whole idea that flash
thompson is a spider-man stand like the
number one
spider-man fan and just because the
account has been posting so much more
the past couple of days doesn't confirm
that they're going to be doing any kind
of spider-man 3 super bowl trailer
but if they do release more spider-man
related stuff this weekend of course
i'll do videos for it
it's more likely that they would release
a venom 2 trailer at the super bowl just
because that movie's
still supposed to be coming in june it
hasn't been delayed yet so fingers
crossed that that date sticks
the more recent posts from the account
though are all about jay jonah jameson's
daily bugle posting more
anti-spider-man anti-peter parker stuff
the way they frame it in these daily
bugle articles is that half the
population believed mysterio and thinks
that spider-man is a criminal and really
killed him and the other half believes
that it's a fake video
from the start that kind of dovetails
with a lot of the easter eggs that we
saw on the set a little while ago there
were a bunch of pictures of it that
posted a couple weeks ago i've already
done a video about it
but on the message board here one of the
easter eggs is for a new organization
that pops up called
citizens to defend spidey so it sounds
like there'll be a small time jump maybe
when the movie picks up or
at some point early in the movie
there'll be a small time jump so that
enough time will have gone by for stuff
like this to set in
people will have time to think about the
video and the other brand new easter egg
that a lot of people have been talking
about
is the feast truck that showed up so
even if you're not a big comic book
reader you probably saw the feast
shelters during the spider-man ps4 game
and it also shows up during spider-man
miles morales
but the fee shelters were created by mr
negative and it stands for
food emergency aid shelter and training
so the whole idea is that mr negative
wants to become the kingpin of crime in
chinatown
but also the good martin lee's side of
his personality wants to help the
community
and that's the side that creates the fee
shelters i don't know if this means that
mr negative is supposed to be in
spider-man 3 but it's possible that they
introduce martin lee and then in a
future spider-man movie they turn him
into mr negative
and a lot of you will know that
wandavision is supposed to connect with
spider-man 3 right now they confirmed
that it's helping set up some elements
in spider-man 3 in addition to a bunch
of other future marvel movies
there's all kinds of theories but just
based on what they've done the past
couple of episodes setting up the
concept for her
alternate house of m reality and the
reality warping powers using cosmic
radiation like the infinity stones
it sounds more like the connection
between the show in spider-man 3 is more
to do with the blending elements of the
multiverse
like i'm not expecting tom holland to
cameo during one division spider-man
isn't going to show up to west view to
investigate what's happening with
scarlet witch
and you also have to remember that the
events of spider-man far from home
take place eight months after avengers
end game one division takes place three
weeks
after avengers end game so one division
technically takes place
a long time before the events of
spider-man far from home
but just based on what we've seen so far
the sword agents and darcy from the thor
movies claim that the threat
that is scarlet witch's reality warping
cosmic radiation powers
might eventually cover the entire planet
and start changing
everything on the fly the way you saw
her accidentally changing things while
she was in the process of giving birth
to her mutant twins from the comics
billy and tommy or wiccan and speed she
effectively created them out of nothing
using her cosmic radiation powers
remember they explained that it's the
same type of energy that created the
infinity stones
the same energy that they give off when
people use them to alter reality or
aspects of the universe
jimmy wu was just wondering about that
amongst other really big questions on
their big
theory whiteboard so post all your
spiderman 3 theories about this in the
comments
how do you think that one division will
set up spider-man 3
my full one division episode 5 video
will post friday just like normal so be
sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss the episodes
and click here for my brand new one
division episode 5 trailer
and you can click here for that brand
new thor 4 love and thunder first look
with the guardians of the galaxy
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next
video
you